you know i struggle with uh
hell everything
but some of those things are
sleep calm focus
etc
you know who can help me beam
beam is a functional wellness brand that
makes products for sleep calm
focus recovery hydration yep that's
right
white chocolate peppermint dream powder
oh
sounds good
they got a special cocoa going on right
now
yep a nice dream powder cocoa you have
before bed keeps you well keeps you
feeling great
head to beam organics dot com slash theo
that's b e a m organics dot com slash
theo for forty percent off your first
three months of any beam subscription
plus a free mug and frother
today's episode is brought to you by
liquid death
happy holidays there
to you and yours
ah
you can kind of feel
the year
it's kind of exhaling a little
you know and that's where i'm at i'm
hoping to be at
i can't tell if
if i'm like
if i'm about to be an ember or i'm about
to be a fire
you know it's that kind of year you know
i want to slither into some comfort
that's what i want to just
just put my whole body in a damn slipper
you know but at the same time things amp
up
you know commercialism is
it's that time of year really
commercialism amp up
you know you see everybody get this
get this deal you need a deal boy
damn it you need a deal
don't you need a deal
somebody stab you and give you a 15 off
coupon
for an emt
just
you know i feel like you're just a
voodoo doll for commercialism they just
get you here you don't you want this two
for one six for seven
damn it
don't you need a schifferoba
you need a wheelchair like i'm walking
who cares dang it buy it
it's just that time of year you know is
you see somebody put a damn uh
a 30 off coupon into a damn uh
what's that like a hole for a body for
dead for dead
into a somebody dead they put a casket
or whatever
somebody put a damn 30 into a casket
like what
that dude's dead that dude's a hundred
he's a hundred percent off
and he he's a hundred percent off of
life
and you trying to hit him with that
thirty percent kim moon
come on
so
it's you know
here we are
um
let's start off with a uh
with a phone call
i'm grateful to be here with you
hey theo what's going on um i've called
him once before my name is will
um i just wanted to apologize
you know right off the bat because um i
did it
i wore a leather jacket to a mexican
restaurant last week um i took my mom
well look
willie
you don't wear a leather jacket to a
mexican restaurant
who are you brother huh
who are you abraham lincoln dude huh
tony hawk
who are you
you don't do it you took your mother i
don't care
if you taking little red riding
out
riding lady i don't care if you got i
don't care if you if goldilocks
if she's all ambient up and you got her
out that bear trap house
and you got her in there
imagine somebody see you're in there
okay somebody see you your mother the
fajita smoke goes by right
it looks like the uh you know the um the
peppers are on there just blowing
winston's just
and then they see you and your mom you
leather jacketed up
and to the because the perception is you
some young buck you some young drug buck
that's hammering down that's hammering
cat on this old lady you out here
hammering cat out here and bringing her
out to some
i'll tell you this if god returns when
he returns he will not you will not you
might you might find him at a cantina
but he
will not
be wearing leather
and you know it ask your heart
and you know it
oh
life is a salad baby and the lord
is my vinaigrette son let's get into it
gang
[Music]
this is robert finley
get it while you can
[Music]
give me a heart attack
you got to take it when you can get
[Music]
there you go right there
ah that is robert finley get it
while you can
happy thanksgiving
happy thanksgiving to you and yours uh
you know i hope this is a time of year
where
you know where you can fill your cup up
you know sometimes i think my cup is a
pitcher
and i i i'll keep pouring
who wants a sip you get a sip you get us
if you have that
i pour a plant a poor person who wants a
cup
you know and and i and i forget that
sometimes you know my cup's not even
full there's nothing even in
and i'm still out there
just drip dropping on people
and so i got to remember to take time to
make sure that i'm doing things to keep
my cup full
you know that i'm putting joy in my own
in my own life so i can
so they'll have something to share you
know
and i got to be doing little thing maybe
you got to pet a little uh cat or
something
you know or bring up a damn jpeg of a
dolphin or something or you know or uh
you know eat a blueberry or do something
good like that
i'll even look i'll look on the video
sometimes soldiers coming home
and then they wheel out you know and
they they they wheel the guy the guy
climbs out of a uh
like a fake uh
easter basket at the uh pep rally or
whatever and you're like oh reginald's
home or something you know everybody's
crying and [ __ ]
and the team so usually they do that
when the team is bad they do that see
we need some damn war daddies over here
and sometime you know it's a couple war
mommies out there you see a couple
you know if you see
you know
if you see a real long kiss and there's
four if there's four breasts and a kiss
baby that's lesbianism baby in this you
gotta enjoy that when you get to see it
so
um
happy thanksgiving uh some people don't
celebrate thanksgiving
i think it's canadians mostly
uh
i don't know who else maybe
canadians they should celebrate y'all
dude
canada's been shut down you guys might
as well start
celebrating it
there's nothing else you guys are so
scared of kova you don't even have i
think you took your door not door knobs
off
this locks only in canada
if you can't if you you got
they're back to writing letters
stationary
the stationary market
up in canada has just skyrocketed
you see ships of ink going up there
yes that you know
canada they
you they're not even allowed to
handshake
no hugging
don't you you'll see a married couple
just staring at each other until one of
them damn busts right out there
or you know really uh sugars you know
really drips out you know drips up they
britches
and they brits dripping out there in
canada because they the laws they've
gotten so coveted scared they
they just
even the snowmen no arms on them
no arms they don't want it nobody's
touching they're not doing none of that
none of that up in canada
what else oh the turkey farmer episode
if you didn't get a chance to check that
out check it out
you know it's nice to learn about the
birds that uh
that really are the mascot of
thanksgiving
you know it's really the baltimore raven
of thanksgiving is the turkey
and a turkey baby that's god's tit right
there son that thing
you know if you put two hands on the
turkey you feel long enough somebody
gone
somebody finding some milk
you could tell by
looking at a turkey that
that bird's hiding that last shea baby
you know
that by that bird
that's 98 degrees that thing's hiding
that nick leche you know what i'm saying
um
we got some great calls man this tree is
close as hell dude
i feel like i'm in
like these things are from vietnam or
something
i keep
hitting it sorry
these things might be listening to me
are your trees listening to you
are you are your artificial plants
listening to you i'm alex jones
i'm how are you
have you had your artificial palms
checked for uh
uh
listen for ears
it never ends let's get into some calls
that came in man always grateful to have
some calls the hotline is always
985-664-9503
here we go
just on my way home from work man i'm a
bartender mixing up drinks probably
spilling most of them but anyway i have
a
thought kind of like a question for you
man
uh there's a lot of performing
characters you know like in the
performance industry
which one out of these two do you think
houses more pedophiles
clowns
or magicians
could hear me out man those clowns
they're coming to your kids party
folding balloons and [ __ ] looking at
stuff you don't you don't know what he's
doing
but that magician
yeah
yeah and thank you for uh sorry to cut
you off man but i but i got these
buttons here and um
it's a good question and it's an age-old
question
you know it's a question you you know
you see old men talking this is
something that's been talked about for a
long time
well first of all let's look at clowns
imagine putting lipstick on your mouth
sometimes you see a man you know your
boy terry or whatever and he does a
lipstick
it's fine you know he says he was in a
fire or whatever and that's why he got
to do it everybody knows
terry never terry never been in a fire
you know terry sherry never been
in a fire terry [ __ ] you've never been
in a fire
so
just be if you want a woman out a little
or you want to you know
you want a small stick on them lips if
you want to do do do what you want to do
then do that
but now imagine a man
instead of just doing a lipstick he puts
a lipstick on his whole face
that's a clown
okay
that's a clown guys and that's
that's where it's alarming
you know uh
when i was young i don't know if you
could even legally be a clown when i was
young
you'd see them get pulled over all the
time they pull a dude over
we had a guy bust he was i think people
thought he just had allergies or
seasonal allergies and uh and that he
was kind of you know a little
i don't want to say they used to call it
fat but he was you know kind of gristled
out you know i'm saying that uh he was
damn the lord's love seat you know what
i'm saying boy
he had a little lever on his hip you
pull on in his legs it goes straight you
know what i'm saying he was that little
comfort bear
and
he uh
he was clown he was clown
and he would get pulled over and i
remember one time they pulled him over
and there was they just pulled him over
for being clown
and
the cops are trying to talk to him and
nobody you know is still kind of vague
what the crime was and then he took his
own clothes off and he had his he had
more clothes painted under his clothes
so he had
and now he's naked now it's a crime
and then
i think the one dude he tried to climb
up a uh invisible ladder like a mime or
whatever you know we shape [ __ ] you know
he's not shape-shifting but he's
you know wishing he was a you know
which is basically the ninja of clowns
a mime is just a damn ninja clown
that's all that is bro
a mime is just a clown that
you know they got its associates really
so he's trying to climb an invisible
ladder and the cops beat him down
um
buddy what was i talking about
but i think a a clown is just somebody i
think that's afraid to ask you to touch
they weiner
that's all it is i think it's somebody
that's afraid to say hey
daddy got that little spice entree you
feel me
because some clown you see the wiener
it's got paint on it that thing it's
like what's even going on here you can't
even
everything's hiding so
the craziest is a female clown
when you see a female clown that's when
i
what
why what ha did you see
was you at a pizza party and somebody
molested you or something you know like
what
you know what i'm saying like how did
you
that's the weirdest one did somebody
like touch your titty at a comic con or
something how why are you a clown madam
why i'm not saying you can't be you can
be but
that's the one that gets me female clown
gets me
but magician magician
magician is just
magician's the one you don't you know
you don't even know you got touched by
him you wake up and you shook in the
head and you shook in the crotch
and you you you know you don't you and
all you did the night before you watched
a couple card tricks and now you
molested like it's just a lot uh
and i'm sorry i know some of this can be
triggering and maybe i shouldn't answer
this question especially on thanksgiving
but um
and look uh a magician is really that's
the silk sheets
of satan babe because
remember silk sheets they're on you but
you can't exactly feel them
you ever get in your grandmother's bed
grandparents have silk sheets because
they freaks bro
and if they if they're not freaks
anymore they want to remember
they want that freak text tile on
you know what i'm saying they want that
spider spit all over their body they
want that silt
so you a silk sh in a silk sheet it can
be on your body and you you can
it's there but you can't fully feel it
it's like there but not there
it's ju it's like uh is this keeping me
warm what is it
and then next thing you know bam
you're molested and that's a magician
it's a silk sheet of of of satan really
i feel like
so
if you had to have someone molest you
would you rather a clown or a
magician rally mal
i would say clown
oh yeah
yeah
why is that bub
i mean just look at him
yeah
i get yeah i guess you you know
you'd rather
it's a more
industrial look i think
you know it's more in it's definitely
more of like a it's more of
it feels a little more union i feel like
getting
maybe molested by a clown you know
definitely a clown huh
i don't know
yeah
yeah you second guessing or
kinda you're just not sure huh yeah
yeah and look and look i'm sorry for
even asking you to choose man it's um
you know it's thanksgiving i don't want
you to get
you know i want you to be happy and and
joyous and free and i don't want anybody
touching you that you don't want them to
and no matter who they are or what their
occupation is
um
[Music]
but
anyway how's it going riley mao is here
the unbustable
doing good yeah yeah yeah how's it going
with the um you know the sexuality and
the
the ejaculate and everything
still the same well my man
that's what i'm talking about son
i bet people get you to damn come cough
on their plants in the spring just to
keep the uh
just i mean you could be mother nature's
little hit man you could be out there
just blooming things anywhere i bet you
walk across a yard and uh
you know and there's gladiolis under
your feet
the unbustable dude
i
dude
i'll trade you for probably nine cartons
of cigarettes in a uh in san quentin
right now i bet you know yeah i bet
elton
elton john we could sell you for half a
million elton john
you'd be a little christmas ham for him
on his dinner table over there
but how's it been man you've been doing
well
yeah yeah what's new in your world
uh
nothing much trying to find a girlfriend
oh really yeah and so with being on in
the podcasting universe some are you
getting a lot of dms from ladies what's
going on
mostly from guys
really yeah oh wow and guys looking for
sex
no
oh just
friendly men yeah oh that's good yeah
and what but no but not a lot of women
huh no only very few
oh
i feel you there dude damn
i feel you there it's all
it's tough i mean it's you know
one will come along i think
but um
do you so do you ever get that nocturnal
kind of bust you ever wake up in the
morning you just check your pants and
just
look for a prize or anything i mean is
there
are you just still wound up huh yeah man
god i almost wanna
man you gotta live stream it man
you gotta live stream when you
live stream you know what i'm saying
baby you got to really show that off ah
what else you got holiday plans
uh yeah i'm going back to california
oh cool man you guys having a little get
together or what yeah yeah just family
dinner
oh sweet you guys celebrate thanksgiving
we do
oh that's good man
welcome brother
i'm glad you're doing well you look
healthy
temperature good and everything yeah oh
that's good man
that's good
oh
you know life hits us different uh
will you stay here we will hang out for
a little while rally yeah awesome man
thank you man and what i'm saying is
this we got a beautiful call that came
in
and so let's get to it right now gang
baby
what's going on uh my name is dalton
i've been listening to the show off and
on for a while now
just want to say i love everything you
do gang game
but a couple dang baby onward
sorry to interrupt you
but a couple of episodes ago i think it
was on the swipe society episode you
mentioned some about your uncle or i
forget who got hit by a train
oh yeah um my mom's brother
got hit by a train i didn't know him
he was dead or i was
i wasn't dead i wasn't alive yet so i
was before you know
i guess i was dead i was you know i just
wasn't alive so
you're not alive when you die and then
you
you're i guess
i don't know if it's dead i don't know
what i was i wasn't i i wasn't on earth
and he was already on earth and then he
got hit by a train he was alcoholic
he was alcoholic and he got hit by train
and that's all i know oh and he was um
brunette
let's hear more
i died and
i can relate because uh when i was in
high school it was probably like
10 years ago i was actually hit by a
train
uh on the way to school i was walking to
school
and
i lived
and uh
yeah i don't know if you want me to i
can send you damn send me what a dog
you gonna send me some arms son i'm just
joking man
wow
that industrial alarm clock baby that
train
gang baby and you hitting the hot line
we got miracles on the hot line let's
play more go on dalton
an article link to the article or
whatever but
it was a life-changing moment for me
like
basically i survived this accident and
if i could go back
honestly i wouldn't change a thing i
would probably
get you know i wouldn't change i would
probably you know still get
such a life-changing moment for me yeah
that's what's up baby i'm upstairs
that's who we are dawg
we are people that get hit by trains and
say run it back fam
we out here dog
god
can you believe it's a miracle riley
isn't it yeah
this man been
he said he said bring it back
let's hear more
that
it was so it was probably the most
important thing
to happen to me in my life it really put
things into perspective but uh
yeah i just wanted to share that though
dang baby he want he he said bring it
back train
two trains
let's run it back
that's powerful man because that it's
like
i i gotta listen to this one well it's
like something happens to you and it's
really
rough it's really bad
and you say that was the greatest
experience let's hear this again this
accident and
it was a life-changing moment for me
like
basically i survived this accident and
if i could go back honestly i wouldn't
change a thing i would probably
get you know i wouldn't change i would
probably you know still get hit by yeah
such a life-changing moment for me
that
it was so it was probably the most
important thing that has
to happen to me in my life that's what's
up we getting hit by trains baby
man it's just like
that's that look man thank you for
calling don't i just
you know i'm sitting here complaining
about this in my life and this is tough
for me in this thing you know and this
is hard and i have this and we got a man
out here
who's getting hit by train
and says hey
let's make it trains baby
who's saying let's run it back fam line
up again
satan
with your big dirty machine
line up again gerald ford or whatever
that guy's name is
whom you know
the train guy larry amtrak whoever it is
line it up
and let's do it again baby because i'm
i'll go one more time that's powerful
that's powerful man
i mean you know
do you feel do you feel the you feel i'm
lifted up here riley i'm lifted up man
because
you know it's like
there's just so much to be learned
through pain
and to get through it and say let's do
it again
i want more
to look your pain in the eyes and say i
want more
cause i'm gonna be i'm gonna be
toughened up
i started off as a damn soft shell crab
i'm gonna finish out as a turtle baby
i'm gonna be toughened up
wow you got me lifted dalton
that's powerful baby
thank you man
thank you very much
thank you for the call you uh
what else you get pubic hair riley mao
you get how's your body doing overall
it's doing good okay
and do you get does it get out of
control or it's manageable for you it's
in a manageable state ah it's pretty
manageable okay that's beautiful dude
could definitely sell you on the market
baby
i get a vpn to hide this browser boy i
get half a million for you somewhere you
know what i'm saying probably sell you
back to your own i'll sell you back to
your own people to be honest with you
praise god brother good to see you today
man
thank you
good to see you man and
uh
and god loves us right yeah
that's awesome
always the best answer
um
what are you thankful for riley
i can tell you i'm not thankful for uh
not having a girlfriend
oh really you really want one huh yeah
at some point yeah yeah and how is it um
and if you had a lot of dates or
anything have you been doing dating i
just had a coffee date with someone oh
okay
okay didn't end well it didn't end well
well how did it start did you would you
wear
um a nice shirt slacks
um
cologne
oh yeah you went there with that scent
huh i did
dude i'm sure you got the pheromones
coming out of your body son
you know i bet you smelled like damn
pure ejac baby
uh
you know what i'm saying i bet a damn
dude
i bet a [ __ ]
a strong dog would lick the skin right
off your bones baby you know what i'm
saying dog damn
oh god i mean you could cry into a uh
you could cry into a woman and and and
she'd have twins man i think um
and and and where'd you all go you guys
went to coffee yup okay
and did you
uh
did you meet her out front did you meet
her inside
um
i met her out front oh
okay
uh
and
did you guys get there at the same time
or
i was there first you were there first
waiting out front yep yeah
yeah i think sometimes that can be kind
of
that's a christian move dawg
honestly that's a hell of a christian
move i respect it it's a [ __ ] old
school
it's an old school move um and so then
you guys went inside and what happened
uh we talked it was great
um i shouldn't say it didn't end well it
ended well um she just never
texted me back and you met her on the
apps i did okay
and were you uh
man i'm bummed out what do you think it
do you think it
do you really feel here's here's the
question did you really feel there was a
connection or are you not sure i wasn't
sure okay
because sometimes i'll put connection
where there isn't really a connection i
want there to be one sometimes because
i'm lonesome and so i'll be like let's
see and
but sometimes they're re you know there
may not be one but right i'm not saying
that's what happened with you no it did
oh it did happen no oh yeah and there
you go but you're still you're not
giving up no you're still out there
and now can you do
uh
and you're saving your sex for marriage
right yeah that's a marriage meal right
wow
so you got to get all the way to the
altar before you can even get these you
know
get that puree out of you yeah pretty
much god
god baby oh
man and now what i mean so you could
now what if you're trapped in an
avalanche or something you have to get
would you guys have to just get married
you to do a sir you figure it out yeah
we'll figure it out somehow yeah yeah
you keep a ring on you at all times but
you must keep a ring in the damn glove
box huh pretty much
riley mouse smiling over there rare to
see him have a feeling um
well i'm sorry the date didn't work out
uh
and we got to get more women to hitch up
now how how far would it be from
marriage to
from the first date to marriage how how
how how quick are you willing to run
that gamut
uh up to anywhere between six months and
a year okay
but in six months from meeting with
somebody you you're ready to hit the
altar
if it seems right yeah if it seems right
and what size woman are you looking for
you got a height range on you
not height
no um i don't want someone that's like
super thick okay but i wouldn't be
opposed okay
so you have to you know you up to a
medium medium maybe a medium plus but
you're not looking for like a bbw or
something they say like that right some
lady that's really like in a
food contest or nothing like that right
yeah i feel you yeah
oh
well
you know uh
they say when it happens it happens
that's what they say exactly but i bet
you got that geyser on your dog dang
you got that mold faithful son that
thing's ready to that thing ready to put
in some work dog dang boy
oh
oh good to see you today um let's get
into some calls man
first i want to tell you about upstart
what would you do if you didn't have
high interest loans or credit card debt
what would you do riley if you didn't
have debt
i don't know a lot of stuff
with upstart you can pay off your
existing debt quickly and easily and
start living your life
if you're carrying credit balance credit
card balance credit balance month after
month it can feel like you're in a
never-ending cycle of debt with no end
in sight upstart is the fast easy way to
pay off that debt
it could be credit cards high interest
loan
funding personal expenses over a million
people have used upstart to get one
fixed monthly payment with a clear
payoff date boom
find out how upstart can lower your
monthly payments today when you go to
upstart.com t-h-e-o that's upstart.com
theo
don't forget to use our url to let them
know we sent you that's upstart.com theo
you know it's that time of year where uh
a lot of men you got that mistletoe on
your body
you know what i'm talking about god's
mistletoe that weiner
cause that thing will you hide that you
you hang that thing over a doorway
during the holidays
somebody gonna
somebody gonna [ __ ] the ant
you know what i'm saying
yeah
well look i shouldn't have said that but
anyway uh what i'm trying to tell you is
manscaped if you have dry ashy skin
you're in luck
man manscape's new products include the
ultra premium
body wash
you wash your body
some creep ass in that one time at a uh
it was um what's that thing where you
drive by you put the money in it and
there's somebody in there in the car
wash
it's like that but no water it's like a
it's by like a bridge or something
[ __ ]
that
touchless car wash
anyway if you're going to start using
body wash you got to make sure it's good
for your skin yep this has sea kelp
extract in it's like being in the damn
motion but you can do it at home
manscaped they've got it all tis the
season
trim up that mistletoe that meaty meaty
mistletoe huh
that long hitter baby if you can't find
a woman would you get you a man riley
no all right there you go boy be honest
say
that's okay you doing good
um i'm just telling you right now get 20
off and support the podcast and free
shipping go to manscape.com
that's 20 off with free shipping at
manscape.com
theo clean up that candy cane this year
with manscaped huh you got a lot of hair
on your body
a little oh that's nice
all right
all right let's get into some more calls
that came in i want to thank you guys uh
and then and i'll tell you a little bit
more about just some of the cities the
tour
um
i'm grateful for you thank you for being
a part of my life
i mean that
i do not know where i'd be without you
uh we got this call that came in right
here let's get into it
hey this is maddie camacho camacho
that's a
native american name i believe and um
yeah thank you for calling sorry about
sorry about everything that happened and
thanks for calling onward wondering if
you know of any tour dates yet that are
going to be happening in 2022 i was
thinking of getting my boyfriend a
ticket for me and him to one of your
shows as a christmas gift i thought that
would be like the best christmas gift
ever
okay
uh sorry uh yes i do think it is uh
oh mommy i shouldn't have impersonated
you there i i i didn't i'm doing good
you're doing good very sweet of you to
think of him oh
that would be like the best christmas
gift ever because we love you but
you didn't know if you have any dates
yet that you yes uh i don't have i'll
i'm coming through florida
i know that uh canada i'll be coming up
to in may
uh florida will be in
uh february
canada will be in or maybe march and
april is canada i think it's april may
april i'll be in canada um
some other places trying to be a little
bit more in the southeast just because
there's less restrictions at the moment
uh so handling things like that
um
and
where else will i be at
uh those will be in the next two weeks
there'll be announcements so there will
be some options i don't know if it'll be
where you are but next year i'm going to
come
uh to a lot of places we're returning
the rat baby
oh and also uh
coachella
california that's december
i think
next saturday what's next saturday the
date do you know
rally mountain move the fourth
yeah this december 4th or 5th in
coachella california at the spotlight 29
casino those tickets are on sale uh
through theovons
theovon.com
tour
so thank you guys for the support there
um
yeah the tour so let's get into the tour
so
we got a tour bus that we leased so that
was really
you know for me it's really about just
having
just just taking the pressure off myself
instead of trying to arrange like
you know or work with my tour manager to
arrange like a sprinter van or this or
that uh
this time we decided to get a tour bus
and it was exciting
you know you sleep in there so it's you
kind of like uh
[Music]
you get it gets a little hamster cagey
you know you definitely
now i see why hamsters have a wheel in
there
because your blood you get real
coagulated you just get real
you know everybody's like on the same
menstrual cycle or whatever even if it's
men you know everybody's just noses will
start bleeding at the same time for no
reason it's just
um
because we just had three men in there
it was myself ari manis who was the
opener
uh and then the the
the bus driver bizzle gibbons uh know is
the tour man
bizzle gibbons
and he's a canuck and uh
and then mr gary was the
the bus driver
and i grew up with a kid named gary so
i'm used to being around gary's
and gary's you got to get used to it
it's easy though gary's are usually
pretty docile
you know
but you got to get used to him
uh and i didn't see the bus driver for
the first four days
because basically you get done with the
show you go to bed
and
he comes on and drives at night
he's almost like um
who's the person that gets in your
dreams and makes you do
or makes things happen riley who is that
do you know i don't
great
uh the guy that gets in your dreams he
like
oh i'll see what i'm gonna do here
like a dream man
you look that up for me do you mind yeah
by the way do you have the password for
the computer
what oh no
you don't have it no
unbelievable never mind uh we'll be fine
man uh
okay
what are we living in people
how many trains have you been hit by son
where are we
this is the problem with society this is
why you know
glad to have you here brother happy
thanksgiving to you
riley
um all right let's just keep it moving
uh
oh but yeah so i never saw gary you get
in there you go to bed you wake up
i got a little bit of nice you know
you know there was one time i had a
little bit of interaction with a woman
you know a little bit of sexual if you
will not full sexual but definitely
you know being around each other and
seeing what was happening
at a close range a lot of close range
basically
so that was good to get involved in a
little bit of close range and know i'm
straight and know everything is chill
always a good time
um
but the nice thing too was sitting in uh
and god bless that woman
and also uh the nice thing was sitting
as the bus drove through the countryside
just sitting in the back
and you're looking out the window and
you're like damn okay beautiful
beautiful let me look over here oh fine
as hell
and it's nature
it's not [ __ ] dog it's nature
because nature is all the [ __ ]
if you really give a good look at it
nature is all the [ __ ] man
and i got my hand in my pants now and
i'm taking it out
okay but here's some questions that came
in from you guys um
just from the tour and stuff like that
so uh
let's get into a couple of them
hey theo man this is max i'm out here in
columbus ohio
i'm uh
big max
and max is as much as you can have so
that's quite a that's quite a
responsibility as a person onward
brother
security uh
guard and visitor experience a gallery
guard at the
columbus museum of art here in the city
watch after that art
oh damn baby so you you garden art
you that freaking vincent van gaan
banger son you out there huh you banksy
siegel
you out there you quick drawing mcgraw
baby garden art
damn boy
keeping them batches off the match of
sketches daddy let's go onward this past
weekend i got to go to your show
uh over at the theater in here in
columbus
first time i got to see you so man that
was huge i've always wanted to call you
and just tell you this this past weekend
i finally got to go see your show
i've been listening to your podcast
since 2018
and i love what you do i really love you
man your inspiration
to me a lot of people so
yeah i just want to call and say thank
you for a great show
this past weekend
i'm still thinking about it how much fun
i had
you were just a fantastic uh comedian
fantastic entertainer and uh yeah i love
you bro all right i just thought i'd let
you know that thank you so much oh
thanks man that's nice of you to say it
dude i i appreciate it i probably let
that go on too long which you saying
nice stuff but
but thank you man i'm glad you had fun
your voice just makes me sound excited
i'm excited because you're excited you
know i'm glad that uh
that we could that you could do that and
feel some
i'm glad you enjoyed it i really am i'll
say this by the time that show got to
columbus that thing was hot
dude that second show i should have done
40 shows in columbus and we'll probably
come back through
um some places you know we just
i've been having to mitigate the left
the amount of shows i can do in cities
because uh just my
i've just been dealing with a lot of
stress and stuff you know but um
but you but dude when i got off those
two shows it was hot
from where this tour started in saint
louis
when people were just you know there was
some guy who was belt he who couldn't
stop belching in like the fourth row
they kept his wife's like
you know doing reverse cpr on him he's
breathing through his wife
just some guy who just had just had too
much meat
you know some guy that was just over
meeted and he can't handle his own life
and now his wife's having to hold down
his uh body air
you know from that from those shows at
the bar that where it was just louder
more drastic and then you get to collect
you get to
whoo
all aboard son
this train don't stop
here anymore
i think that's an old song i don't know
if it is or not [ __ ] i might have made
that [ __ ] up i might have never even
heard that should you ever do that
you already started singing a song you
don't even know if you ever [ __ ]
heard the song baby gang
um
but thank you brother you stay hot on
that art fam
let's hear another call that came in
right here man uh
gang gang hey theo this is alex from
maine i i saw you in portland this past
tuesday with my girl
i was a guy wearing a shirt with bananas
on it that fruit shirt hitter
uh the show was awesome you were so
funny man
thank you alex uh thank you for bringing
your lady out and making the evening it
was a guy if you've never been to
portland maine
it is
amazing city
amazing it
blew my mind that that's what was
happening up there that that's what god
put up there
i thought it was a couple people up
there you know what i'm saying
freaking trying to you know use a
crowbar to get it up in each other's
clam holes you know what i'm saying a
lot of people out there
trying to use a damn shoehorn and trying
to shoehorn their way into a little neck
gang baby onward i was just curious did
you in the show early because of the
kind of loud possibly drunk people who
kept yelling out
there was a lady a few roasts behind me
who yelled out like your ass is hot or
something
and like people laugh white lady
probably off of it but then she did a
second time a few minutes later and you
looked a little bothered um oh they want
that gristle daddy
um
no no i didn't earl i didn't um
portland show let me think
no we got off state oh no i remember
we didn't end early i think we did about
a 50-minute set and then
um
we did a meet and greet
or you know just
well i was feeling pretty good my energy
was feeling good and so we uh got to
meet some people uh you know just
just met who was around so
i think that was
pretty much it i loved it there i loved
portland that tuesday night you know i
have a special place in my uh ticker
uh
in my heart me corazon
for portland
you know i used to
i remember touching a girl's body when i
was young up there
off of isles burroughs island
and i don't know who
i think it's named after like larry
isles burroughs or something i don't
know
but
oh
i remember being in an abandoned summer
home in an attic in maine and touching
some girl's body and a bat tried to
attack me same time
and it's hard to play the fiddle when
freaking satan's trying to you know when
he's sending one of his little hit men
at you
you know when he's sending that little
[ __ ] dirt sparrow at you dawg
so
you know when voldemort's got that
little [ __ ] uh
you know when uh
you know you got that voldemort's goose
out there hitting the air that bat
so that was tough i remember trying to
you know be really you know i was young
and i was trying to really enjoy this
girl but you know my you know we were
doing body time a little bit you know a
lot of close range
and
that bat so anyway i have a special
place in my heart for me
and man they can't everybody out there
is insane is crazy
everybody out there is like a crazy dog
maine is crazy man
we got some lobsters we went and uh
the late i was like how's the lobster
she's like it was swimming out there
yesterday
and she literally pointed to the water
so that's god baby
that's god dude
that's god's sink up there maine
so there we are
i'll tell you this man uh we'll get into
some more thank you guys for being here
today i'm gonna let you know that mint
mobile offers premium wireless service
starting at just 15 bucks a month
and when i heard it i said where's the
catch this seemed fictional
well
after speaking with them and using their
service it all made sense there isn't
one
mint mobile's secret sauce is that
they're the first company to sell
wireless service online
only by cutting out retail stores that's
what they do
so i know it's tough to realize that
that's where we are in the world but
that's where we are we don't need the
store sometime you can just get the
product
yep for people looking for extra savings
mint mobile offers premium wireless just
15 bucks a month
all plans come unlimited talk and text
on the nation's largest 5g network to
get your new wireless plan for just 15
bucks a month and get the plan shipped
to your door for free go to
mintmobile.com
theo that's mint mobile.com
t-h-e-o cut your wireless bill to 15
bucks a month at mintmobile.com
theo
oh
you know i i'll tell you this
my testosterone it gets a little dicey
if i'm in traffic that [ __ ] is hot
you could you know
my kettle is rocking baby i got some
steam coming off of me
you could hear that whistle
you could hear that whistle in my
missile baby
but a lot of guys have started using
replacement testosterone replacement
therapy that is true
if you're experiencing symptoms like low
energy or fatigue erectile dysfunction
yup
low sex drive or libido anxiety brain
[ __ ] uh enlarged breast tissue bloating
headaches jesus christ who is this guy
um
i'm excited to share today's sponsor
with you it's
let's get checked that's right let's get
checked as the leader in at home testing
yep that's right simply go to their site
order the mail hormone advanced testing
kit it arrives in a small discrete
package
do a small finger prick send the sample
back to their lab
and it arrives at your door
back to their lab with prepaid shipping
label in two to five days you get your
results let's get checked mail hormone
advanced test the perfect kit to get a
comprehensive look at your male hormone
levels know your levels always important
it's fast affordable convenient and
totally confidential use code t-h-e-o
for 30 off your entire order
at
try
lgc.com
theo
that's lgc stands for let's get checked
try lgc.com
t-h-e-o that is code theo for 30 off
your entire order at trylgc.com
theo if you want to know what's going on
with your levels if you think
something's going on
at least now you can know
how you holding up riley
i'm doing great yeah
what are you getting for christmas you
asking santa for anything or anybody or
you're somebody parents um yeah asking
for a girlfriend
[ __ ] really man yeah
are you joking with me or you really
want a girl yeah wow
bub
man
now are you worried that if you if a
girl come along you could just
she might not even what you know you're
just gonna take you know sometimes
somebody serve you something and you
don't know what's in the kitchen because
you haven't really had a had a snack
right are you worried about that at all
not really
and how quick can you get from first
date to marriage do you think in y'all's
religion
i'm not sure
there you go
damn
well
you never know boy damn
you willing to get there though yeah
definitely say you meet a girl she seems
great how quick would you be willing to
get to marriage
four five six months
yep amen boy
amen dude you better sell ticket you
better sell a live stream when you get
that stream live baby you better sell
you know what i'm saying you better
definitely sell eight buck tickets
i'll sell it to it i know a couple dudes
out in l.a couple uh
executive producers that would
definitely pay to see some of that
action
all right let's get into a couple more
calls here um
here we go
hi theo
it's ava from maryland
um i'm calling cause i just got what's
up ava
from maryland baby let's go
um i'm calling cause i just got home
from your show we were just performing
in baltimore and it was awesome
i um
thank you thank you that's sweetie to
say it
ah
some of them run together a little bit
but not always um
i think it was a pretty big venue in
baltimore
so thank you for coming out i bought two
tickets initially because
i was going to go with my boyfriend but
we're not together anymore so
i couldn't find anyone to go with me so
i just went by myself and
i felt kind of uncomfortable
um
and then once you got on stage you know
it was just
the energy in the room
was just it was just so full of love you
know and
i didn't even notice you know that i was
there by myself anymore um it sounds
kind of lame but
you were awesome you were great we loved
you
um come back soon please we all want to
buy tickets
oh gang baby thank you thanks for the
nice words and thanks for being brave
enough to go somewhere by yourself
you know we're all by ourselves in a way
in the world
well you know we have you have but
you're all there's this you know the
mainframe is in us
you know we see out of our own eyes
you know we have our own perceptions
so in a way we're always kind of all by
ourselves but i i can imagine yeah i get
if i got to go eat something by myself
i'm like i'll pull the waiter over i'll
say bring the appetizer fast don't leave
me sitting here doing nothing
i'll tell us tell them straight up
dude riley there's a lady right there
i know
and why i mean are you how do we you
know
are you missing these babes man
we got to get you out to a beach or
something maybe where the babes are yeah
i'm down
um
but thanks for coming ava thanks for
coming in there solo i'm glad there's
you know there's a lot of love in these
audiences i agree you know i constantly
hear from people it's like the best
group um
you get some free birds you get
people crazies as well but a lot of love
out there and uh i just think it's so
sweet that even that you you decided to
come even though you know your man
bailed out he missed out that's what i
say
that he missed out
but you didn't gang baby
um
what else do we got here
[Music]
i feel like that's a lot of stuff so far
what else oh they have some new merch
available we got a new bait a new like
uh fish in and outdoor kind of line that
is available
so you can check that out at
theovonstore.com
um
let me see what it says because
uh new get that hitter bait and tackle
collections
availables
black friday sale going on now through
monday november 29th at 9 00 p.m
20 off all be good to yourself and get
that hitter merge gang
also the new i'm upstairs collection is
available
uh
so new designer tees long sleeves and
hoodies
yeah a lot of neat lot of nice christmas
gift options um
also if you are a patreon member we have
low patreon but if you're a patreon
member you get you'll get early access
for ticketing and uh
you get discount codes uh for merch
so just letting you know because we
don't do a big patreon over here
um
you know we do a lot of just a
money for single moms and that sort of
uh deal
what else oh what else happened on the
tour let me think about that
ah
we almost went to the osu game but it
was getting cold and we'd had a long
couple of days
you know because by the time you get to
a place you get going it's noon
um
[Music]
uh
oh burlington
oh this happened in a couple spots
people have to wear the uh mask now
in some theaters
and i didn't know it
so in burlington's man i'm out there i'm
i'm i'm giving it my all
and i'm like man i don't the response
i'm not feeling some of the response and
then halfway through i realized
these people are wearing masks
i didn't even realize it
and um
and that kind of became a theme in a
couple of the places we were
you know that theaters would ask them to
wear masks some people would some people
wouldn't
uh
which is fine i you know
do you
you know if you want to have a mask i
have it on
um
i felt like but the requirement of it
that was a little bit that was that was
tough
because some places they would make you
or they would come and say something to
you
so
i just want to say thank you to
everybody who's putting up with that
kind of stuff i know it's not easy
um
you know just dealing with that sort of
thing
so
uh
i know it's not easy i know it's not
easy i don't want to look past that i
want to say thank you yeah because some
people bought tickets and then they
realized they have the
the theaters put in these mandates
and andrew schultz just said [ __ ] you to
a theater and went to another place
and um
and i love that and and i would do that
too i think uh
you know i got to get a better i oh he
went not because of mandates he went
because
they said he had offensive material they
didn't want his type of material or they
gave him some notes
and good
[ __ ] them
[ __ ] them people
uh
the p people should be able to pay to go
see what they want
i i'll then also believe people
should be able to go to a place where
they know people are going to be masked
or not masked
i mean this shit's almost ridiculous now
most people have forgotten they even
cared about covet that's the crazy part
i have friends like eight months ago
that were like
you know that maybe didn't have some of
the same thoughts i did about it and now
they forgot about it
they wouldn't even be around you know
and now they forgot it so it's like
i think a lot of that stuff is i think a
lot of that's kind of dissipating
you know when i look back on certain
things that had my energy or that were
making me upset it's like
you know you read articles now about
like uh blm found you know uh
guys still fighting for blm like in
parks and stuff it's like what
the people that came and that money
sailed
the
t-shirt vendor for that he showed up
he's gone now
you know it's all these little things
come that get our attention get our
money they get your money
they got you get donated seventy dollars
to some damn to a
black arts foundation and that that guy
got busted or whatever and i'm not
saying it's just a blo i'm not saying
just black name it could be anything
it could be a damn uh
you know norwegian
um
you know orange company
and you out there eating all these
oranges for these [ __ ] on a saturday
getting vitamins seed up and next thing
you know they leave town they don't even
they don't give a damn
damn you know
vitamins see you later these [ __ ] out
all they was in town to get to get the
cash
and you but we forget about it
thankfully we forget about those things
too can you imagine if the stresses we
had just stayed in us forever
well that would be me um
anyway i don't really know what i'm
talking about
uh
we had some uh in the last episode we
had
um
i gotta pee guys i'm gonna be right back
what else is going on let's get into a
couple more calls man not to be call
heavy but i just haven't gotten to spend
time with you guys in a while and so i
like to hear what's going on uh from
your end what were the other shows like
on the tour let me think um
oh in albany man we got to be in this
building called the egg
so the bus pulls in at night i don't you
know you don't know so
we go up in the elevator we're
downstairs
and suddenly i'm off
what do you need
honey can you i'm upstairs
i'm upstairs
god i love it
uh
so oh [ __ ] was that talking about
wasn't talking about riley
the downstairs on tour oh yeah so we got
stuck in the uh there we go yeah
hell yeah finally riley
you know you hold out hope that a guy's
gonna there's gonna be something in him
for as much as that's trapped in this
dude you think some information would be
stuck in there times have changed okay
species are different people are
different
um
this theater dude in the uh albany dog
this [ __ ]
it shocked me
this thing it looked like a oh
it looked like a bowl of like low main
or i don't know what the hell look we
got images if you're on youtube man we
got images you will be shocked that
there is a building that looks like this
in america
you'll be shocked
i had no and we were inside it
so someone tagged me on the gram in the
story and said hey is this where you are
and i'm like [ __ ] i guess so
i guess so dude
and that's where we're at as humans we
don't even i don't even know what
building i'm in
i just know that i'm
upstairs god what do you want
um
so that was wild oh walking down the
streets of albany dog that [ __ ]
i didn't know albany was any i didn't
know about it
you know if somebody said you know hey
albany i'd say
what are you saying guy
what are you saying
could you draw a picture of albany new
york
i don't think i can
and uh so that's what i'm saying here is
that i didn't know and then we walked
down the streets afterwards and it's
like all these blustery leaves blowing
and
big leaves those big ones you know
all winterized they're browned out you
know
these things are all blm'd out these
leaves
and they're on the ground just like
just like map like ancient maps
you know they look like a map from like
a different civilization from like a
different
galaxy or civilizations
and so you know
it was beautiful though it's beautiful
it's it's unique
uh
some dude outside some dude said hey
i'll give you a 40 buck he said hey give
me 40 bucks and i won't beat the [ __ ]
out of you
and i'm like all right
i'll do that dude
i got that same deal over in delaware
son i've seen this deal
so that's a you know that's that safety
tariff baby i paid that [ __ ] straight
up son
that's that safety tariff
um
if you ever finally did get to ejaculate
riley mount would you keep it or you'd
let it go
uh
i'll let it go oh man
you'll wish you had it later i know it i
always wish i had mine
so just a just a side note and nobody
has to know you keep it
right
but um
what i'm trying to think of anything
else i mean it was all great coming out
on the stage seeing everybody's hyped up
in buffalo we got to go see the bills
stadium my boy harrison phillips over
there plays football over there he's a
football guy
and he plays number 99
and i got to go in the locker room man
got to see aj klein's locker and
um
who else uh tr uh
uh
diggs mr diggs is locker
and um josh allen's um
you know we got to be in there and look
and touch like the medical tape and
stuff
and then we went out to the field there
was a high school game
going on some children playing
you know and uh
you know joey diaz would have sprinkled
a little bit half an eight ball out
there but whatever dude that's different
guy different time but
um
but that oh here was great
so we're in buffaloes and we go to the
uh
see the tour of the stadium
and afterwards we got a car to come pick
us up because we don't have a car that's
the thing about the bus if you're in the
bus
the driver's gone all day he's asleep
somewhere he's at a holiday inn select
or like at a hampton inn
which is where i hope to be buried at
you know that
and
uh
what happened
what was i talking about riley you
remember it
uh the bus driver hampton inn
before that
oh the bill stadium so we get in the car
to leave it's dark now
we start driving about 10 feet in the
driver
you just hear him go gang gang
and we're like oh [ __ ]
so we were so hyped man this guy he had
a crazy story he told us all this wild
story about drugs and youth pastoring
and all kind of [ __ ] you know some real
total gang gang gang [ __ ] you know what
i'm saying what kind of stuff you hear
on here
so it was really but it was crazy we're
just sitting there in the dark and we're
just heading back and we got it you know
the show starts in an hour and 20
minutes and then you just hear gang gang
and he said that him and his wife were
going to the show that night and uh
and they were gonna go to dinner first
but this call came in and he took it
because he's just doing work and
and next thing you know he's picking us
up and he's like it's just kind of wild
you know
so he took us to get some wings and then
dropped us off and
we got to meet him and his lady leah i
think was his wife's name
after the show for a bit and say hey you
know
and that was cool man just the people
you meet
um
and
you know we didn't put a meet and greet
on the tour because it was uh i just
been stressed it's been hard to know
what your stress level is gonna be
and so
it just have to take it i try to do it
when i can so if some places i didn't
get to meet some of you i'm sorry
you know
and we'll try next time
and in other places sometimes i'm just
feeling okay
uh but i gotta have something in my cup
you know
because otherwise i'm just getting out
there and we all
you know and then i'm not myself and i
don't want to be not myself
i'm tired of that i can't be it anymore
i'm tired of it
uh
all right let's get one more call or two
that okay let's get one more that came
in man we had some stuff about uh
hearing compliments and stuff and
we'll get into it next time
i want everybody to go enjoy their
thanksgiving enjoy their thanksgiving
week
um
i'm excited
i'm excited just to yeah i got some
family i'm gonna see
and i'm looking forward to that
here we go man
here's a call that came in
hey what's up theo um
i'm giving you a call
is
uh i just
i'm downstairs man i just got a lot
going on in my life
i kind of don't feel like i have anybody
else talk to you right now
it's just hard
uh i've been there baby
i've been there man thank you for
sharing onward
we got some bad news about my
mother-in-law she's got stage four
inoperable cancer
and
you know
my wife and i have white are two small
kids
i work full time
i'm doing grad school at night
and uh i don't know it just feels like
things are falling apart for me lately
i'm trying to
find joy and
not let anybody take my joy but it's
hard
it's hard right now man uh you know like
my marriage is
situations kind of coming between our
marriage because it's hard i don't
i don't know how to be the best
to everybody just be strong you know
it's hard man i
i wanna
i just wanna hug
probably nice
but uh i thank you for your podcast man
it helps
sorry
no don't be sorry dog
i just wanted to say thank you
i'm just being here
the bright spot in my life
and i'm thankful for that that thank you
joy
thank you brother
gang man thank you bro
thank you for calling in thank you for
sharing what's going on with you and
just in a real way
um
you know i was crying somewhere
yesterday at a starbuck
so i'm damn crying at a damn starbuck
you know
and here was the crazy part that i'll
tell you this is a true story
i'm not trying to laugh i'm just but
i
literally had been crying at it in my
truck in a starbucks dude right
so look
some guy dry he's in traffic on the road
out in front of me and he's like
he's like what up [ __ ] he starts
like flips like [ __ ] he's just
flipping me off and then once he gets my
attention he's like
you just but i'm just like
little did he know i've been sitting
there freaking
you know
just letting all these [ __ ] ghosts
outside you know
you know the ghosts inside of us
whatever they are they turn into water
and come out of our face you know um
and i don't know if i should even keep
that i don't know maybe we'll keep this
call in i don't want to be
uh
disrespectful to you by putting your
feelings out there
um
but it's a lot yeah i think we all feel
a lot of pressure
to be everything it's this never-ending
thing and i think it's so sweet that you
care about your mother-in-law most
people
would go to a they would go somewhere
and buy stage four inoperable cancer for
the mother-in-law
you could sell kits of that on etsy
right now
a lot of it would be women
using fake mail screen names or email
mail emails
to buy it for their own mothers
you know the devil's in the the devil is
out there man
but
you're doing good man i'm just here to
tell you you're doing good
and uh
wow i feel like i'm talking to myself
you notice don't be so hard man it's so
funny these are all the things that
people tell me
wow
and i don't even have a family or kids
or a real job you know what i'm saying
you out here doing real stuff man you on
the front lines baby
you getting hit by trains baby
you know so it's okay dude you know it's
okay and you know why because a long
time ago men was in it was in groups and
tribes
and if you had a feeling you would share
with somebody and you had somebody right
there to be there with your feeling
and just don't be afraid to lean on the
people around you you know just hug your
wife a little extra hug yourself a
little extra
you know i think you're doing great man
you sound
if you're brave enough to share what's
going on with you man damn
that's huge dog
it's huge you doing that just lets me
know i'm okay
i'm not carrying any shame for being out
of damn starbuck i'm out there
you know putting extra salt water in my
damn salted caramel
baciate or whatever dude these [ __ ]
or whatever i don't know
but
sorry i'm not much help right there uh
you're doing good man
you're doing things i'm afraid to do
have a family have a wife
you giving me strength
you know and they need to get a damn hug
machine at the cbs dawg that's what they
need huh
you might ask it on a date on riley if
it was
yeah there you go but they should have a
cbs don't have a damn hug machine at it
they got a red box for one dollar you
can somebody can come up behind you and
mug you
that's all red box is
you you get up there you put a dollar in
and somebody jack your ass from the back
and now you sitting there you got a copy
of damn you wake up you know
two towns over
and you're being sex trafficked or
whatever
but you got a copy of uh
of a home alone three in your pa you
know stuck in your pants in your pocket
it's just
but they need a hug machine at the cbs
dog and when i see you i'm gonna give
you one
and just thank you for you know just
sharing your truth bro
and sharing what's going on and i'm sure
look you hear this voice man you
probably left this voicemail a week ago
and you're in a better place now oh
but we'll all be thinking about you know
your mother-in-law and
and just uh
giving you the strength man
what do you do riley when somebody
doesn't have strength what do you all do
over at the church what do you all do
i just pray over them
and you have to physically be over them
like a fire you can do it like uh over
zoom or just
over anyway you could just do it by
yourself right now if you wanted huh
right you just think about them
yeah
we'll be thinking about your dog
i'll tell you that
[ __ ]
half a million people listen to this
show there's half many people that have
been thinking about you while this
shit's going on
but maybe that might make you feel more
comfortable if i told you that many
people but it's so funny i feel like i'm
sitting there listening to myself for a
second so thank you for sharing thank
everybody that's come out to the shows
man and being a part of my life uh
and let me be a part of your life
you know that so often i can't love
myself and uh
and you guys love me
and it's crazy
you know it's just that that's what we
do for each other i think
we just love each other until we can
love ourselves
gang gang on that
you know what i'ma go out a good way man
it's an old-fashioned way it's the way
how we all got in some of this
[Music]
come on happy thanksgiving everybody
tell them riley happy thanksgiving i'm
just sitting on your front porch
wondering how could i be so far from my
home
thanks for being here with me today
right thank you theo i appreciate it
yeah i appreciate you man thank you to
spencer leatow
for uh
producing and editing this episode
thank you to colin
[Music]
ryan thank
you when i reach that ground i'll share
this peace of mind
i can feel it
[Music]
but it's gonna take
a little time
for me to set that parking brake
and let
[Music]
sit and myself you my stories
baby
you like this song riley i do yeah i do
[Music]
oh
i'll sit and tell you my story
shine
on me
and i will
find a song we'll sing it just for you
and i will find the words to help you
make it through
if you call my name
[Music]
that light on me come on raleigh now
let it loose baby
let's go taiwan baby
and i will
find a song
i'll sing it just for you
[Music]
me
[Applause]
[Music]
oh man
life is a salad baby and the lord is my
vinaigrette son
you guys be good to yourselves
uh you deserve it that is um
shine by bishop gunn
and the beautiful vocals of mr travis
mccready right there unprecedented
talent in that band bishop gun and uh
i'm gonna keep them on my thought list
so i hope they can put it back together
i'd love to see them back out there
making good music we all would you guys
be good to yourselves uh
i'm thankful for you gang